.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Einen Zentimeter rauf.
Nicht zu weit rauf.
Jetzt kannst du etwas rauf.
Wir müssen die Rollen rausnehmen.
Diese Wohncontainer konnte
die Stadt Zürich nicht mehr brauchen.
Das brachte den Holzbauunternehmer
Andreas Seiz letzten Herbst
auf die Idee, die 28 Container
in die Ukraine zu bringen,
für obdachlose Kriegsopfer.
Es ist besser, den Leuten vor Ort
Perspektiven zu geben.
Sie haben es wirklich dreckig dort.
Und jetzt wird es Winter.
Ich finde einfach: Am Ende des Tages
müssen die irgendwo sein können.
Es muss ihnen warm sein, sie müssen
zu Essen und ein Zuhause haben.
Erst wenn die Grundbedürfnisse
befriedigt sind,
haben sie Perspektiven.
Das sind wir ihnen schuldig.
Ob die Containeridee
von Andreas Seiz eine gute war,
davon handelt dieser Film.
* Ruhige Musik *
In diesen Wohncontainern
waren ursprünglich Asylsuchende
untergebracht.
Aber sie genügten dem Energiegesetz
der Stadt Zürich nicht mehr.
Seiz übernahm die Container
mit dem Versprechen,
diese in die Ukraine zu bringen.
Die Aussenbeleuchtung und alles
sind komplett funktionsfähig.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Das ist die Dusche mit WC.
Männer und Frauen sind getrennt.
So ...
Braucht das wirklich jemand?
Besteht der Bedarf?
- Also ...
Haben Sie das abgeklärt?
- Ja, ja. Das hat ...
Das hat ...
Yuliia hat das alles abgeklärt.
Ich kann das nicht beurteilen.
Aber darum gehen wir hin.
Wir sehen es dann.
Aber man muss noch abklären,
ob jemand das braucht?
Nein, wir haben eine Liste erhalten.
Das fand vorher statt.
Ich wollte wissen, wer darin wohnen
wird und ob sie es brauchen.
Sonst würden wir
die nicht hinfahren.
Das haben wir gemacht.
Wir fahren nicht einfach blauäugig
mit ein paar Containern
in die Ukraine.
Der Prozess
ist schon lange abgeschlossen.
Das machten wir als Erstes.
Dann kam die Frage des Transports:
"Wie bringen wir sie hin?"
Die grössere Aufgabe
bzw. die Knacknuss war,
zum heutigen Punkt,
also zum Verladen zu kommen.
Schweizer Transportunternehmer
wollten den Auftrag nicht übernehmen.
Zu kompliziert, zu heikel.
Ukrainische Lastwagenfahrer
sprangen ein.
Obwohl die Container gratis waren,
verschlingt das Projekt viel Geld.
Ich bezahle gut 200'000 Fr.
Das ist unsere Eigenleistung.
Was unsere Leute hier machen,
ist nicht inklusive.
Ich habe aber schon
einen ähnlichen Betrag
an Hilfswerke gespendet.
Das fand ich nicht befriedigend.
Ich sehe gerne,
was vor Ort passiert.
Andreas Seiz
ist Besitzer und Geschäftsführer
der Hartwag Holz AG in Buchs,
Kanton Zürich.
Unlängst hatte diese
ihr 100-jähriges Jubiläum.
Das Hilfsprojekt
sei auch Ausdruck von Dankbarkeit.
Wir sprechen immer
von unserer humanitären Tradition.
Das beginnt mit solchen Projekten.
Das ist keine staatliche Aufgabe.
Wir sind historisch gesehen
so privilegiert ...
Wir dürfen wirklich anderen Menschen
helfen, die es nötig haben.
Ich kann ja nichts dafür,
dass ich in eine vermögende Familie
in der Schweiz geboren bin.
Das ist ein Privileg.
Also kann ich etwas zurückgeben.
Der ukrainische Botschafter
Artem Rybchenko
gibt sich beim Verladen die Ehre.
Er bedankt sich
auch bei Yuliia Petermann,
einer gebürtigen Ukrainerin,
die seit acht Jahren
in der Schweiz lebt
und das Hilfsprojekt mitmanagt.
- (Frau) Stopp, stopp, stopp.
Ein Geschenk?
- Ja.
Aber ich
war noch nie in der Ukraine.
Das ist ein Vorgeschmack.
- Ein Vorgeschmack?
Als Dank für Ihre Unterstützung.
Das hilft gegen Covid.
- Ah ja? Oh!
Nemiroff Vodka - super.
Das ist eine Spezialität aus
der Ukraine - mit Pfeffer und Honig.
Danke.
Okay, dann bis nächstes Mal.
Und ...
Gute Reise in die Ukraine.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns dort.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Anfang Dezember fahren
Andreas Seiz und Yuliia Petermann
zum ersten Mal in die Ukraine.
Die lange Reise führt per Zug
von Warschau nach Kiew.
Es war Petermann, die den Standort
für die Container gefunden hatte.
Durch Freunde fand ich eine Gemeinde
in der Region Tschernihiw.
Sie verkuppelten mich mit Vertretern
der Militäradministration.
So ging das.
Aber es war nicht einfach,
das alles zu managen.
Es gab
viele organisatorische Fragen.
"Wie kommen die Container? Wann?
Was wird alles organisiert?"
Ja.
(Balzli) Gestern wurde Kiew
wieder massiv bombardiert.
Haben Sie keine Angst,
es könnte etwas passieren?
Doch, ich habe Angst.
Aber, wie Herr Seiz sagt:
Wir müssen mit dem Herzen
und positiven Gedanken hingehen.
Dann werden wir geschützt.
Alles kommt gut.
6. Dezember -
Ankunft am Bahnhof Kiew.
Der erste Anblick:
ein von russischen Raketen
beschädigtes Bürohochhaus.
Fahrt nach Tschernihiw,
2 Std. nördlich von Kiew.
11'000 Gebäude
wurden nach ukrainischen Angaben
in dieser Region zerstört.
Das Stadtzentrum dagegen
ist fast unversehrt.
Besuch
bei der Militärverwaltung der Stadt.
Diese hat den Standort
für die Zürcher Container vermittelt.
Wir sind auf einem guten Weg.
Sag ihm, ich danke
für die Unterstützung bis jetzt.
* Yuliia dolmetscht. *
Danke.
Die Militärs
hatten sich zuvor am Telefon
nach einer finanziellen Abgeltung
ihrer Dienste erkundigt.
Als die Leute aus der Schweiz
ablehnen,
kühlt sich
das Interesse der Männer merklich ab.
Sag ihm, ich wisse schon,
dass das nur ein Tropfen
auf den heissen Stein sei.
Das konnte ich halt auf die Schnelle
selber an Hilfe mobilisieren.
Immerhin: Die Militärs zeigen
der Schweizer Delegation ihre Stadt.
Das war das regionale Spital.
Das Quartier rund ums Spital ist
besonders schwer vom Krieg betroffen.
Auch die Polizeizentrale ...
... und die Sozialbehörde der Stadt.
Sie ist aus dem ersten Stock.
- Abala! Iditje sjuda!
Eine Rentnerin
zeigt den Besuchern ihr Quartier.
Seiz, gelernter Bauingenieur,
schätzt die Schäden ein.
Das ist ein Totalschaden.
Das kann man nur noch abbrechen.
Da unten bricht es raus.
Und das Element ist tragend.
Die sind aufeinandergestellt.
Hier unten ist es kaputt,
also reisst man alles ab.
Sie sagten uns, in diesem Gebäude
seien 58 Menschen gestorben.
Und für noch viele mehr
ist es nicht mehr bewohnbar.
Die haben
eine Wahnsinnsaufgabe vor sich.
Dann geht es zu Fuss über den Fluss.
Die Brücke für die Autos
ist zerstört.
Ankunft im Containerdorf.
Die Bürgermeisterin ist vor Ort.
Ein Drittel der Container aus Zürich
ist bereits aufgestellt.
Doch schon beginnen die Probleme.
Sie haben kein Holz daruntergelegt.
Unten ist kein Holz dazwischen.
Hier gehört Holz rein.
Kann man das noch besser machen?
- Ja, kann man.
Nein,
man  m u s s  es besser machen.
(Balzli) Gehen wir mal rein.
Ah, jetzt. Tipptopp. Ja.
Da hinten
ist die Dusche mit WC und Lavabo.
Hier ist dann die Küche.
Es braucht noch
etwas Vorstellungsvermögen,
um zu sehen, wie es wird.
Sie haben die Container
schon mal richtig hingestellt
und sie richtig verbunden.
Unten machten sie einen Fehler
mit dem Auflagern.
Das müssen wir ausbessern.
Aber das Material ist komplett hier.
Alles ist da, wo es hingehört.
Das ganze Material hat den Weg
von Buchs nach Krasne gefunden.
Das ist schon mal ein Aufsteller.
Jetzt müssen wir
mit der Bauleitung schauen,
dass sie es richtig zusammensetzen.
Darum sind wir hier.
Yuliia, komm mal.
- Ich komme.
Frag, ob sie die IKEA-Möbel
überhaupt brauchen.
Ja, die brauchen sie.
Wir müssen nichts kaufen,
das sie nicht brauchen.
* Sie sprechen ukrainisch. *
Alles bleibt hier.
Wenn etwas übrigbleibt, haben sie
Familien, die das bekommen.- Gut.
Mehrere Personen, die ihr Heim
verloren haben, sind gekommen.
Sie interessieren sich
für einen Platz im Containerdorf.
Olena Chomenok ist eine von ihnen.
Im Moment
kann ich mir gut vorstellen,
hier mit meinem Sohn zu leben.
Unser Haus ist ja zerstört.
Hier drin sieht es sehr schön aus.
Olena zeigt uns,
wo sie früher gewohnt hat.
Jeden Tag kommt sie hierher,
um ihre Hühner zu füttern.
Im Hühnerstall
steht noch das Dachblech,
das von einer russischen Rakete
zerfetzt wurde.
Und mit ihm das ganze Haus.
Das ist alles,
was davon noch übriggeblieben ist.
Man hat uns im September
einen Wohncontainer versprochen.
Aber es hat noch nicht geklappt.
Ich wohne noch bei einer Bekannten.
Es hat eben hier in der Gegend
so viele Leute,
die ihr Obdach verloren haben.
Olena hat nur einen Wunsch:
Eines Tages
ihr Haus wieder aufzubauen.
Es ist schon spät.
Aber die Bürgermeisterin
will uns noch das Schulhaus
im Nachbardorf Yahidne zeigen.
Das steht: "Vorsicht Kinder".
- Ah, okay.
Hier im Keller hielten russische
Soldaten in den ersten Kriegstagen
über 300 Dorfbewohner als Geiseln.
* Die Bürgermeisterin
spricht ukrainisch. *
In diesem Zimmer
waren 140 Erwachsene und 39 Kinder.
Wahnsinn.
Nein, das ist ...
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
27 Tage lang
waren die Geiseln hier einsperrt -
als menschliche Schutzschilder.
Ohne Tageslicht, ohne Toiletten.
Die Luft war stickig und heiss,
die Räume überfüllt.
Die Russen
erlaubten oft nicht einmal,
die Latrinenkübel zu leeren.
So wurde es hier unten
schnell sehr unhygienisch
und bald starben die ersten.
Einige
der wenigen Fotos aus diesen Tagen.
Die russischen Besatzer
kannten kein Erbarmen.
Es gab Tage, an denen es die Russen
nicht einmal erlaubten,
die Leichen rauszuschaffen.
Hier starb eine alte Frau und die
Kinder spielten neben der Leiche.
Die Bürgermeisterin
zeigt uns die Listen
mit den Namen der Verstorbenen.
Der erste Junge auf dieser Liste
war 22.
Er wurde erschossen,
weil er "Ehre Ukraine" sagte.
Diese sieben
wurden von den Russen erschossen.
15 weitere starben an Krankheit.
Trotzdem: Sie erlaubt sich
keinen Hass auf die Täter.
Ich spüre keinen Hass.
Ich möchte einfach,
dass sie unser Land verlassen.
Und vielleicht wird Gott
ihnen geben, was sie verdienen.
Die Bürgermeisterin
betont das Positive.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Sie sagte: "Wir haben Freunde."
"Wir haben Kollegen.
Wir haben Familie."
"Wir haben jetzt auch
Unterstützung aus der Schweiz."
"Gott sei Dank wurden wir
nicht vergessen. Mein Gott."
* Düstere Klänge *
Am nächsten Morgen:
Die zweite von drei Ladungen
mit Containern
trifft aus der Schweiz ein.
Viel später als ursprünglich geplant,
aber vollzählig.
Es ist schön, dass sie hier sind.
(Balzli) Es gibt noch viele Probleme
zu lösen, scheint mir.
Mmh ... Nein, ich ...
Für mich war ein grosses Problem ...
... dass sie überhaupt
hierherkommen.
Und ich glaube, mit diesen Leuten
hier finden wird den Weg.
Wenn ich mir diesen Kran ansehe ...
Bei der ersten Lieferung stellt
der lokale ukrainische Bauunternehmer
eine viel zu teure Rechnung.
Deshalb
entlädt jetzt eine andere Firma.
Wir merkten, dass uns der erste
Unternehmer über den Tisch zog.
Deshalb mussten wir
einen neuen Unternehmer suchen.
Jetzt ist einfach
das Fundament noch nicht fertig.
Wir müssen die zweite Reihe mal
auf der ersten zwischenparkieren.
Aber die
ist gefüllt mit Hilfsgütern.
Im Eingang hat es immer 1 t Reis.
Und die Zimmer
sind gefüllt mit Hilfsgütern.
Wie kriegen wir die Ware runter,
wenn wir die
einfach aufeinanderstapeln?
Darum müssen wir kurz überlegen,
wie wir das machen.
Doch für jedes gelöste Problem
scheint ein neues aufzutauchen:
Die Bürgermeisterin
möchte möglichst rasch
das ganze Material vertraglich
in den Besitz der Gemeinde bringen.
Das ist sackteures Material.
Auch für Schweizer Verhältnisse.
Das will ich ihnen nicht schenken.
- Ja.
Aber die Container
können sie meinetwegen haben.
Das ist okay.
Aber einfach den Container
mit dem Generator,
plus so eine Kiste plus Werkzeug.
Das bleibt bei uns.
Yuliia
übersetzt und erklärt nach Kräften.
Bei der Ukrainerin wächst der Ärger.
Es gibt immer noch
viele bürokratische Sachen.
Das ist immer so in der Ukraine.
Obwohl da humanitäre Hilfe kommt.
Die Übernahme und das Vertrauen
sind ein bisschen kompliziert.
Haben Sie nicht Angst,
dass etwas verschwinden könnte?
Doch.
Darum müssen wir
auf Papier richtig regeln,
wer für all die Sachen
verantwortlich ist.
Bis jetzt
ist niemand verantwortlich.
Ab heute
werden wir das auf Papier haben.
Die Baufirma
wird das alles übernehmen.
Dann braucht er noch zwei Wochen,
hat er uns versprochen,
bis die dritte Reihe bereit ist.
Das ist Routinearbeit.
Die dritte Reihe
geht dann automatisch.
Das geht dann schneller.
Ein weiteres Problem: Die Gemeinde
will Strom und Wasser nicht bezahlen,
solange sie
nicht die Besitzerin der Anlage ist.
Um die Blockade zu lösen, übernimmt
Andreas Seiz die laufenden Kosten.
Es brauchte einfach wieder
einen finanziellen Befreiungsschlag.
Ich habe hier so viel Leid gesehen,
so viel Kaputtes ...
Die paar Franken
bringen mich definitiv nicht um.
Aber mit dem nicht genug:
Die Wärmepumpen laufen auch nicht.
Deshalb können die Container
nicht beheizt werden.
Und darum
kann auch noch niemand einziehen.
Zwei Tage später
unterschreibt der Schweizer
einen Vertrag mit dem neu gefundenen
Bauunternehmer namens Ivan.
Dieser verspricht, die Wohncontainer
bezugsbereit zu machen -
bis Mitte Januar.
So. Tipptopp. Komm.
Komm.
Ja, super.
- Gut.
Habe ich. Ja.
Zwei Monate sind vergangen.
Andreas Seiz und Yuliia Petermann
reisen wieder in die Ukraine -
diesmal
mit zwei Schweizer Fachleuten.
13 Std. dauert die Reise im Nachtzug
von Warschau nach Kiew.
(Balzli) Wenn Sie jetzt
mit Dezember vergleichen:
Was ist seither passiert?
Ja, eigentlich sollten
alle Containerreihen aufgebaut sein.
Es sollte alles zusammengebaut sein.
Was wahrscheinlich noch nicht
funktioniert, ist die Wärmepumpe.
Deshalb sind wir jetzt hier.
In Krasne ist es bitterkalt.
Doch die Container
sind immer noch unbewohnt.
Seiz sieht dennoch das Positive.
Es sieht schon viel besser aus.
Das haben sie im Griff,
auch die Hölzer unten.
Und es ist cool,
dass sie den Strom dran haben.
Haben Sie Strom?
Ja.
- Okay.
Aber es fehlt noch eine Bewilligung.
Also
ist noch kein Strom auf der Leitung.
(Balzli)
Ist das jetzt diese Wärmepumpe?
(Mann)
Davor hatte ich am meisten Angst.
Das müsste man sauber abkleben.
Das muss man lösen.
Für die ganzen Anschlüsse,
elektrisch und kältetechnisch.
Komm.
Der Kältetechniker
und der Heizungsinstallateur
schauen sich die Sache an.
Meine Hauptsorge ist,
dass der Frost ein Problem ist.
Wir haben Wasser am Boden, die
Anlage ist ein Stück weit gefüllt.
Wir haben nachts
tiefe Minustemperaturen.
Deswegen wurde wohl eine Leitung
oder ein Teil der Anlage beschädigt.
Ivan, der ukrainische Bauunternehmer,
erklärt, was er erledigt hat
und warum er mit den Arbeiten
in Verzug ist.
(Ivan) Es waren
zwei sehr interessante Monate.
Aber die Brücke über den Fluss
war für uns
fast die ganze Zeit geschlossen.
Wann sind die Container
bezugsbereit?
Kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Aber in maximal zwei Wochen
ist sie sicher fertig.
In maximal zwei Wochen.
- Gut.
Machen wir sicher mal zwei.
Er versprach es bisher
immer schneller,
als es wirklich passierte.
Aber das sieht ...
Es ist wärmer als letztes Mal.
Ja, ja.
Es ist immer noch eine Baustelle,
aber ... Ja.
Aber wir kommen vorwärts.
- Eben.
Für Yuliia sind das Momente,
in denen ihr bewusst wird,
was ihrem Land noch alles bevorsteht.
Ich weiss,
dass es nachher viel Zeit braucht,
um alles wieder aufzubauen.
Die Menschen ...
... sind traumatisiert.
Das Land ist ökonomisch,
also wirtschaftlich zerstört.
Das ist wirklich ...
Sorry.
Beim Rundgang
tauchen neue Probleme auf.
Oh Mann!
Warum stellt er die so weit weg?
Das sagen wir Hans noch nicht,
sonst dreht er durch.
Und auch das Prunkstück der Anlage,
der 20'000 Fr. teure Generator,
springt zunächst noch nicht an.
* Stotternde Geräusche *
Auch Bauunternehmer Ivan zeigt sich
als nicht einfacher Partner.
Als Höhepunkt hatte er Seiz um
eine Viertelmillion Franken gebeten,
um seinen Geschäftsmitinhaber
auszubezahlen.
Seiz lehnt höflich ab.
Die beiden Schweizer Fachleute
arbeiten derweil zielstrebig
an der Reparatur der Wärmepumpe.
Wieder vor Ort:
Bürgermeisterin Olena Schwydka.
Sie erzählt,
es gäbe bereits Wartelisten
für die Plätze in den Containern.
Es gibt bereits mehrere Familien,
die hier einziehen möchten.
Familien,
die ihre Häuser verloren haben.
Und wenn wieder Leute aus
der Grenzregion bombardiert werden
und zu uns flüchten,
können wir sie hier
vorübergehend unterbringen.
Jetzt stellt sich heraus:
Die Gemeinde will definitiv
kein Geld für den Betrieb
der Containersiedlung geben.
Es ist einfach so:
Ich muss mich damit abfinden,
dass sie kein Geld haben.
Aber es läuft darauf hinaus,
dass wir alles zahlen
und die Gemeinde nichts.
Ich bin natürlich
nicht so ins Rennen gestartet.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
wir würden die Container aufstellen
und dann sei gut.
Aber das funktioniert nicht.
Wir finanzieren auch den Betrieb.
Es geht nicht anders.
- (Balzli) Wie lange?
Über mehrere Jahre, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns
auf fünf Jahre oder mehr einstellen.
So, läuft es?
- Ja, ja, es kommt langsam.
Hey, super. Was haben wir hier?
55 ... 35.
- Ja.
Tipptopp. Gut. Läuft.
Hey. Ja, komm.
- Let's shake on it.
Hey, jetzt läuft's.
Ich bin erleichtert, dass wir
das Minimalziel erreicht haben
und eine Anlage läuft.
Sicher. Das ist ein Happy End.
Das ist ja immer gut.
Trotz schlechtem Wetter:
Die Laune heitert sich auf.
Eigentlich war es wunderschön:
Die Ukrainer
haben es super vorbereitet,
sind aber
auf den letzten Metern gestolpert.
Hätten wir alles machen müssen,
hätten wir es auch nicht geschafft.
Miteinander
haben wir es hingekriegt. Schön.
Wir dürfen
die Ukrainer nicht unterschätzen.
Sie haben einen wahnsinnigen Willen.
Sehr einfache Mittel ...
Wir sind anders geprägt.
Aber miteinander
haben wir es hingekriegt.
Das ist superschön.
Das gibt eine tolle Geschichte.
Freude herrschte für Andreas Seiz
auch wenige Tage später:
Er ist mit seiner Holzfirma
an der Giardina präsent,
der grossen Gartenmesse in Zürich.
Er gewinnt einen Preis
für seinen selbst kreierten Garten.
Ich muss keine Ideen suchen,
sie kommen zu mir.
Das ist ... Das ist toll.
Und es funktioniert alles.
Hier kann man Wasser rauslassen.
So.
Ich finde es wichtig ...
... dass auch eine Messesituation
real daherkommt.
Das ist sonst nur Fake.
Bei uns nicht:
Was wir bauen, funktioniert.
Das ist ein Grundprinzip bei mir.
Es hat Fake-Situationen:
die Schmetterlinge z.B.- Ja, gut.
Wir mussten uns überlegen,
wie wir den Motor
ohne Sonnenlicht zum Laufen bringen.
Ich gab Gleichstrom
mit einem Eisenbahn-Trafo.
So 6-7 V.
Dann ging es aber immer noch nicht.
Also musste ich
einen Widerstand reinlöten,
damit es die richtige Tourenzahl
gibt. Anfangs war er zu schnell.
Gewisse schauen,
ob es auch so noch läuft.
Und es läuft immer noch,
obwohl keine Sonne draufscheint.
Das ist eben das Fake.
- Das ist das Fake.
Die Welt, in der wir uns befinden,
ist spannend.
Wenn ich in die Ukraine gehe
und wieder nach Hause komme,
brauche ich eine gewisse Zeit,
um anzukommen.
Das ist
so ein grosser Unterschied ...
Von kompletter Zerstörung
und auch menschlich
sehr schwierigen Situationen
kommt man in diese Show-Welt
in einer Messehalle.
Das ist ein extremer Spagat,
den man da macht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Mai - Frühling in Krasne.
Das kriegsversehrte Dorf
im Norden der Ukraine
hat ein kleines, neues Quartier,
das einst in der Schweiz stand.
Heute ist Tag der Einweihung.
* Sie spricht ukrainisch. *
Das ist ein Dankeschön
der kantonalen Gemeinde.
Danke.
* Ruhige Musik *
Mir ist klar, dass jeder
am liebsten sein eigenes Haus hätte.
Aber das ist eine Übergangslösung,
die funktioniert.
Ich wünsche Ihnen Gesundheit
und alles Gute. Vielen Dank.
Danke.
Again.
Bauunternehmer Ivan
nimmt den Schweizer auf den Arm.
Diesmal wortwörtlich.
Gut, du kannst mich runterlassen.
* Yuliia spricht ukrainisch. *
Im Grossen und Ganzen bin ich
zufrieden mit unserer Arbeit.
Die Bürgermeisterin sagte,
sie hätte schon schlechtere
Containerdörfer gesehen.
Ich bin stolz.
Auf die ganze Arbeit bin ich stolz.
Allerdings: Bisher ist erst
eine einzige Familie eingezogen.
Sie flüchtete einst
aus dem Donbass nach Tschernihiw.
Dort wurde ihre Eigentumswohnung
letztes Jahr
von russischen Bomben zerstört.
Eine Weile
lebte sie im Keller der Ruine.
(Balzli) Gefällt es Ihnen?
(Frau) Ja, es ist alles bestens.
Das hier haben wir
noch aus unserem Dorf mitgebracht.
Es hat überlebt.
Das einzige Möbelstück.
Das ist ein Schrank.
Schon alles drin.
Das traditionelle Wyschywanka-Hemd
ist auch schon bereit.
Hier möchten wir
einen Computertisch,
sobald wir wieder Geld verdienen.
Und hier
einen Schminktisch mit Spiegel.
Schliesslich
wachsen hier ja Mädchen auf.
Auch unsere Bekannte Olena
hat ein Zimmer bezogen.
Aber einziehen will sie nicht mehr.
Sie kommt nur zum Duschen her.
Ihre Hühner
seien zu weit weg von hier.
Viele sind heute auch aus Neugier da:
"Mal schauen, wie es so ist."
Ein paar Familien
ziehen an diesem Tag aber auch ein.
Und doch: Eine von drei
Containerreihen bleibt leer.
Very good.
(Balzli) Aber die grosse Frage ist:
Ziehen wirklich Leute ein?
Im Moment sind wir
noch nicht sicher, ob sie das tun.
Ja, ja.
Da drüben ist ja schon
eine Familie mit drei Kindern.
Hier sind Leute ...
Bei meiner kurzen Ansprache sah man
Leute mit Tränen in den Augen.
Das kann man nicht vortäuschen.
Die haben
keine Schauspielausbildung dafür.
Die Frage ist,
ob immer alles ganz voll sein wird.
Aber es gibt ein Kommen und Gehen.
Die Leute
haben hier ein erstes Zuhause,
nachdem sie alles verloren haben.
Die Gewissheit haben wir.
Mit dem investierten Geld,
rund 300'000 Fr.,
hätte er im Dorf
auch 15 kleine Häuser kaufen können.
Hilfswerke sehen private Projekte
ohnehin eher kritisch.
(Balzli) Jemand von einem Hilfswerk
sagte mir,
Private
sollen nicht Hilfswerk spielen.
Die sollen
mit Hilfswerken zusammenarbeiten.
Dann wäre es billiger
und besser rausgekommen.
Was antworten Sie darauf?
- Ich habe meine Zweifel daran.
Unter dem Strich
haben wir jetzt Platz für 40 Leute.
Und wir haben das innerhalb ...
... sieben Monaten geschafft -
Projektbeginn bis zum Bezug.
Wenn ich ausrechne,
wie viel so ein Platz kostet ...
... sind wir extrem gut unterwegs.
Und v.a. kostet das nicht
die Allgemeinheit, sondern mich.
Man muss nicht das eine
gegen das andere stellen.
Beides ist gut.
Die einen machen dies,
die anderen das.
Ich bin happy,
dass es funktioniert hat.
* Ruhige Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023